you
all right it's a great pleasure to
welcome Lea Louisa
Moss from the University of Bamberg Lea
is a master student in the applied
computer science program she was a
student to Schmidt who worked on the
igor programming induction system today
lea Louisa is going to talk about her
experience with making the Egor system
more usable through a web-based
interface just to put things in context
one of the things that realize is that
program synthesis and programming by
example is becoming an increasing part
of the technology that all the major
companies are offering to make empower
people to empower them to do tasks etc
so this this work on thinking about how
to make it accessible to people how to
explain the results of it cetera to
people is really fundamental in
understanding how to make this
technology really reach as large an
audience as possible so thank you very
much thank you all right so welcome
everybody and I want to start things off
with talking about inductive programming
for a bit I don't know if everyone is
familiar with the concept and induction
in mathematics describes inferences from
particular cases to the general and in
computer science inductive programming
is basically the same it uses a set of
specific equations to generate Universal
functions and this principle is useful
when repetitive tasks have to be
performed so the developer does not need
to implement the functionality each time
by hand and therefore has time for more
complex tasks and in addition to the set
of those example equations information
like background knowledge can be given
to the inductive programming system so
the computation of functions may take
less time - thereby more efficient the
functions that are being generated often
recursive as you can see in this example
we have three examples for a function
called last and for last with the input
a it should have a as an output for an
input a B it should have B and for an
input ABC it would have C so the
function should always return the last
element of the list with inductive probe
we get this function that is applicable
for every possible input so if the input
has one element then this one element is
just returned and if the input has more
than one element then the function is
called recursively with the list but
without the first element of this list
one of these inductive programming
systems is eager to which was
implemented by the University of Pam
back in the programming language mod and
eager to generates hypothesis based on
input output examples and those
hypothesis mod functions and eager to
usually needs approximately four input
output examples to derive those
hypothesis and it works with previously
defined internal data types so the
programming language mod itself has data
types but eager to need special data
types which are also defined within
eager to an eager to the algorithm can
be described as a uniform cost search
which means that the hypothesis with
minimal costs are used for replacement
and returned by eager to now let's talk
about the usage of eager to and I
mentioned earlier that you got to
basically only needs input-output
examples but when you look more closely
it's much more difficult and much more
that is needed eager to needs an input
file which is Mark module within this
smart module you have to define the
module name and the sorts that are
needed for the function you want to
generate so for the example last my item
in my list I needed which are both eager
to internal data types and after that
you have to define the Constructors for
these data types so you have the
constructor for the empty list and the
constructor for every other list which
takes an item and a list append the item
to the list and then returns the list in
line 9 you can see the
definition of the function last and the
input is of type my list and the output
is of type my item in addition to all
that here are the input output examples
which basically should be the only thing
the user should provide but in reality
isn't and you have the variables X Y Z
which are of type my item and then you
have the three example functions once um
have this input file 911 that's just
something that eager to needs which is
eager to specific so this has to be
stated in every fire no not really
okay okay so once you have this input
file you can then call a reduce command
which is in what you say that you want
to reduce an ego and the module last and
the function last this no name means
that you provide no background knowledge
because for the function last no
background knowledge is needed but if
you would need some background knowledge
you would put in the function name there
and down here is the output that ego to
generates you can see the number of
rewrites it took to generate these
hypotheses and the time it took and
those here are the hypotheses as you can
see they are in ego to syntax and are
not that easily to read and you cannot
test the function this way because it's
not mod code so you would have to
translate it if you translate it you can
then test the hypothesis by calling
again a reduced command you want to
reduce in the module last and then you
have to put in the function call and
after that mod returns as a result my
item D which would be career
for this input only input-output
examples and if you want to know more
about ego too you can read those two
papers and the source code of you got
who can be downloaded at this address
looks like the hypothesis came up with
don't match the ones that you've shown
in the previous slides worried because
it looks like it's either staying minute
so one item one story item oh I see no
x2 could be nothing okay um so now that
you've seen how he got to works this
leads me to a question you go to is it
usable for everyone well first of all it
requires knowledge of constructor terms
and in addition the interaction is only
possible via terminal and one has to
call mod commands so the normal user
might not be familiar with using the
terminal and might also not know how to
write lists as constructor terms and so
on so interaction with ego true needs to
be much more intuitive who's the user
basically everyone maybe software
developers which might be familiar with
these constructor terms but also the
data types are eager to internal so
maybe they won't know them but basically
everyone who wants to derive functions
or who's interested in inductive
programming and maybe wants to try out
the system and so the solution is easy
ego which is the web-based front-end I
have developed and you can see here that
the user can put in the function name
the input the output and then just has
to state the data type I will show this
in more detail later on with a live demo
and but now I just want to talk about
how easy ego works so here we have an
overview you have the user and the user
interacts with easy ego of via an
interface and is ego has two main
components the translator and the tester
the user types in the input-output
examples and then the translator
translates them and then called ego
which in turn returns the hypothesis
these hypotheses have then to be
translated again and are shown to the
user and in addition they are being
saved as a mod module because they are
needed for testing purposes later on and
if the user now wants to test the
hypothesis that were being returned he
can call an example function call which
is then being translated by the tester
and then being called by mod with the
use of this mod module this that was
written previously by the translator
mark then returns the result of the
function call and then the translated
result is displayed to the user via the
interface and the user can see whether
or not the hypotheses were correct
before I talk about the algorithms I
just want to say some words about the
data types here we have four data types
two lists integer and boolean so this
list contains items and this contains
integers this is the way the user can
put them in in easy ego and this would
be the way the user would have to put
them in if the user would use you got to
directly so instead of using using this
constructs or this success of zero terms
the user can just put in the list like
this or put in an integer like this and
to make this possible
a few algorithms have to be implemented
this algorithm is to transform a list
that contains items and so first of all
the converted list is being initialized
as an empty list and then the items are
the elements that are being extracted
from the list to convert so in this case
the brackets and the commas are removed
and then only the items are being left
after that the algorithm it iterates
over the items and for each item the
item is appended to the converted list
with this constructor terms so you have
cons then the item and then here is a
placeholder where you can put in the
next cons and the next item at the end
when every item has been appended the
converted list is being returned another
algorithm is to transform integers and
to do so first of arrival called
converted nut is being initialized with
zero and after that for I between zero
and the nut that is supposed to be
converted the converted nut is being
surrounded by s and by brackets so at
the end you get as many s and brackets
as the number that was being put in now
when you have converted the input you
have to save it in a file for this I
have a file template and all that is
written in caps is being replaced and
either by directly with the user input
so for example the function name can be
directly am replaced by the user input
but some things aren't given by the
users for example the sort constructors
and they are being taken from fire that
is being provided so if in the needed
sorts there's for example a list then
the list constructors are being written
here after the examples are being saved
in this file template and the hypotheses
are being returned the I post with
himself to be translated to make them
testable so at the top is the return of
ego two and at the bottom is the
translated version in mod syntax so
basically you replace every X that has a
number after it and the data-type so for
the first hypothesis X zero my item gets
replaced by a in both cases and in the
second hypothesis you have X zero my
item that's being replaced by B X 1 my
item by a and X 2 my list by G and after
you have replaced this then the
hypothesis can be tested so yeah exactly
because this cannot be tested directly
it has to be translated and after it was
translated then the user can put in the
example function call which then again
has to be translated because he would
put in the list in his fashion and not
in ego to syntax and then the function
would be called
but the return of the function and also
has to be translated because it could be
that the function the user wants to test
returns a list and this list also has to
be translated into this non constructor
term fashion so the user understands it
and for this they are algorithms within
the tester this algorithm is to
translate a list from eager to a syntax
the user can understand and this is done
by again initializing a variable
converted list with an empty list and
then the elements from the list that's
supposed to be converted are being
stored in an item's list and this is
done by removing the punctuation and the
cons so only the items are being left
after that the algorithm it iterates
over the items and appends each item to
the converted list and then returns the
converted list the algorithm for
transforming an integer
um but you have the converted list and
then you just append the item right so a
is the first I don't yeah and then you
just okay and you have the
transformation of an integer you have
the variable count that is being
initialized as 0 and then for I between
0 and the length of the integer that is
to be converted which is a string and
the algorithm checks if the character at
position I equals s and if that's the
case then the count is being increased
by 1 so what the algorithm basically
does is count PS in the string and then
just return the number if you're dealing
with large integers long string yeah
it's really really long string I don't
think so I don't think that ego too can
deal with flowing point numbers um okay
so now that you've seen how easy ego
works and I want to draw a conclusion
and talk about future work easy ego
allows for intuitive interaction with
ego too but it also has to be said that
it only supports a subset of
functionalities of ego - at the moment
I'm subset because only one input
variable at this moment is possible so
if you want to derive a function that
has more than one input argument that's
not possible and in addition it's at
this moment also not possible to provide
background knowledge which are both
features that are implemented in ego -
but not yet in Easy ego knowledge with
you could you provide an Ivar - and well
how would that transition with the user
specified give an example
and the background knowledge can be any
function so you have to provide the
function again in this file input file
and maybe it can be the reverse con so
instead of appending an item to list its
to put it at the front so that can be
some background knowledge a function
that does that and then it can be used I
think for the reverse function so and
then it's when you get a reverse
function with let's say equations okay
so future extensions for EASYGO would be
additional data types for example an
embedded list which is a list containing
lists and in addition background
knowledge which would be which would be
useful for more complex functions and it
should be possible to have functions
with more than one input variable so
those are all things that should be done
in the future to improve easy you go and
the way it works now I would like to
give you a short live demo of eazy-e go
easy ego can be reached under this
address and can be tested let's see okay
so this is the web interface and then
you can just type in function for
example last and then you have to state
the input and the output for each of the
examples you want to give so let's say
we have a list with a different number
of elements
and after having put in the input so
what is the select for the datatype do
it what does that say what datatype
you're telling it about and it's the the
type of the input yet so you see you
haven't selected list of alpha right
nope yep okay getting to bed yeah so
here the data types so you have integer
lists with integer list alpha objects
and pool so in this case the input would
be list alpha and the output would be of
type object then you can just submit
let's see if it works okay so this is
what II go to returns already translated
into mod syntax here you have the
variables which are my item a and B and
minus G and down here you have the
equations which is here a list
containing only one element and here a
list containing an element followed by a
list containing an element and now if
you want to check if this is correct you
can just click test hypothesis
and then you can put in an example
called
okay so you have a function name and
then the input which is a list ABCDE F
and then you can test the hypothesis and
you can see that the result is my item F
can you give an example where there are
two competing hypotheses which might be
correct you had a list of three L events
and you always basically a last element
and now the choice could be it is the
third index or it is the last index
um can you repeat the question
so let's basically put in inputs where
there are lists which have or all the
lists have three elements mm-hmm and we
will sort of the output will be the last
element but now there is our alternative
hypothesis which is that the third
element is the output okay so I want to
find out whether the system bar so it
gets the last one or basically find out
whether it's the third one
so like this you mean right okay
approximately by example reversing it
you okay so it looks like it's always
returning the third element I see okay
now actually so so with that particular
formulation what if the list has more
than four elements or more than three
elements you're just I didn't know more
them here on earth so doing test
hypothesis on that just want to see if
you give it for what happens
okay so it's not able to so is Igor
always using recursion is that the only
way wait yes basically um if you can it
handy oh it cannot handles I can't
handle strings
well list of words and internal strings
and lists of words no objects in this
case only means like variables a b c d
saw the alphabet
okay
yes so what happens if input is a list
and you want to add some constant
sequence of elements at that so the
example could be lets say input is ABC
and output is basically a microsoft be
microsoft see microsoft
change
yeah just add another MICR Oh at the end
so ABC and then we will add em I see no
so so we output is ABC yes the same this
table is yeah okay
so they're always sweating not replenish
the great thing about this is it instead
of learning eager yeah function
okay so this doesn't seem to work I
don't get any variables or equations I
guess the reason is that probably it's a
binding for them I am this may be a
shame what you say might take 400 if you
can get audience know what my sense is
that my ability yeah what if you have a
b c a b another output
yeah if you see a B and D F D yeah and I
provide revenue ABC in a B so half the
outputs has final five elements ABC a a
B and D F D G H I J an output which is
Massino GHI yeah right
it seems like you should translate
laundromat as translation you should
translate the equations showing it in
acid exit Snapple money yeah so maybe
that's also future work to just change
that yeah but this seems to work okay um
just gonna show one more example um
great verse can you do just with the two
it's been worse
okay well this would only work for one
so you need third example to generalize
yeah an arbitrary number let's see
seriously I got this one so how long can
you know so these are a lot of equations
that's what I said earlier because yeah
you have a lot of functions now simple
okay yeah I mean right if I put it which
is kind of interesting because if I put
in poor examples
cuz I've tried this yeah
then it states that you go to a strain
rate it more than one hypothesis so I
don't know why it works with three but
not with four but it seems like when you
have these four input output output
examples then there's more than one set
of hypothesis with the same cost so ego
doesn't know which one to return so in
this case it helps to just put in the
empty list as some sort of base case and
then if you
submit it again you get the same
equations as before but with this base
case
in addition so interesting that it works
for three examples or not with more so
the thing it generates is like a
personal function over the domain I
think so we saw an example again this
one where there were inputs where it
didn't happen it didn't ever result is
there any way to tell yeah I mean it
stated earlier that it needed more
inputs I don't know why when we put in
the other examples that it was just
blank because yeah I don't think that
you can really tell just by getting the
hypothesis back because you go to
doesn't say that it's only a partial
function so that might be something to
improve but I mean the user would see
when testing the hypothesis that it
won't work so that's that sort of a set
of operators that Igor do searches over
is it just these primitive yeah
basically I think you got who can also
deal with objects and other data types I
think that the university has tried the
towers of Hanoi with ego too but that
will work with either easy ego at the
moment but it's also something that can
be thought about in the future because I
think you got to is much more powerful
but it's kind of complicated to just
yeah start and work with ego too because
there's a lot of to complete a lot you
have to consider so what do you mean by
that it's not robust waves
you know I don't think so okay can we do
a natural natural example and see you
into regression linear regression maybe
it's just I don't know let's pick some
why cuz 3x plus 1 yeah 3x plus 1 okay I
don't think that would work actually
because what data type would it be if
you mean that I am the input would be if
everybody like 1/4 okay yeah
in output you can replace 4 7 n by 2 3 4
okay oh and one that works yeah I guess
the most part because the successor
navigational representation yeah go to
Dubai yeah you're multiplying okay so
three four and it was from the second
output yeah yeah old and physics
okay doesn't seem quite the same session
because you use the same function this
is generating normally it should
override it but yeah okay yeah I think
it's limited to to a simple addition
almost like symbolic it's successors for
like an ordering as symbols yeah I don't
think so
easy you go up and I don't know if you
go to Ken so about counting counting the
number of in the list can you do that
I don't know haven't tried it actually
so like counting the number of elements
terrible these translators mod is not
terrible pest say it's more like the you
go to data types that are kind of
difficult but not also is yeah not so
pretty as a language but you are you see
that would be hard to learn that just
what we three examples right yeah I'm
not even sure if it would work what
happens if you change this boom just put
all there and just put zero one presence
or absence of a presence or absence of P
is false no it's just maybe reduce this
face I think maybe this will work if you
have more than one input argument so
maybe you can have as a second input
argument the the character that should
look for so that's maybe something that
you go to can do but with easy go right
now it's not possible